Two men lost their lives in a
crash in 96 How are you, Cristian
Cásseres greets you, everything happened near
Chayanne and Cérvix streets downtown on
Sunday night, authorities report
that two of the motorcycles were traveling
in the direction of Chayanne street and
crossing lanes was  they collided with a
van both cyclists died
while two other people were
hospitalized police revealed that
high speed was the cause of the
accident
46 people have died from
accidents in the state of nevada
so far this year the report also reveals
that  the number of deaths on the
roads and highways of the state decreased
by 15% compared to last year,
among the main causes of these
fatalities driving under the
influence of some substance and
speed 16 of these road deaths
were pedestrians and 9 did not have the
seatbelt on
the war on the other side of the world
continues to impact gas prices
nationally carried
again reaching new records
according to triple-a the average price of
fuel is five dollars per gallon
last year during the same date the
cost was three dollars and 19
cents we have more information on
the gas stations with the lowest
prices  on our page at news now
dotcom and we start the week with
pleasant temperatures Monday will be
mostly sunny with temperatures
reaching 72 degrees and with little
wind the hottest day of the week
will be Tuesday when some areas of the
valley could reach 80 degrees  So
don't forget your glasses as we will see
several sunny days for the rest of the
week. I'm Cristian Cásseres with his
brief informative on excited in
Spanish, good day
[Music]